there certainly was no Blue Wave and
there it does seem like Republicans are
maybe kind of getting that what is what
does Joe Biden always say the ramrod the
Republican ramrod is here people anyway
here's uh Democrat activist Jake Tapper
on CNN talking to new house Democrat
leader Hakeem Jeffries reminding him
that no you guys didn't really crush it
this time actually you were kind of
defeated I want to ask you though uh
you're you're portraying a very Rosy
scenario about how well Democrats are
doing you just lost the house I mean
your party was just defeated at the
house I get that it wasn't as bad a
defeat as it could have been uh but it
wasn't exactly a vote of confidence in
house Democrats
but what I'll say is that it was
historic over performance by every
single measure uh almost Beyond
comparison when you look at the last 100
years what does he mean though historic
over performance you lost the house you
lost Latino voters Florida became
solidly red New York almost flipped and
sent a couple congressional seats to
Republicans California even sent a
couple there is some weird stuff
happening here but yes of course they
just lie about everything and that's
what they do and yada yada I think you
got what I was selling today on the show
did you get it